rub what I love this place was a good  man the best of us you know they have  walking trails in England pubs come on  look we go Southwest through here  we caught the journey in half what  through the forest yeah why not should  have gone to Vegas  oh you'd have found something to fall  over in Vegas to me now is it me what  was it really quiet here it's been  gutted could be hunters out here mate  possibly or is the bit they don't show  you in the nature documentaries a  warning we shouldn't be here we to beach  the tents  it's a ridiculous man won't you think so  either  no I didn't hear anything come on  so we're gonna talk about then oh no it  was a nightmare Phil all happened to you  then you got spooked and we had bad  dreams  alright nothing was done that - you've  done it to yourself  if you have to deny everything cuz I do  not value your judgment we need to be  working together man  [Applause]  Oh  what the [ __ ] is that  you  you